Julie trying to pick one of these out  anything about this one  oh sorry did you not understand what do  you think I'll prove it for this one  what do you think about that thank you  so much thank you oh no come on you're  making us all look bad  oh not again  Zoe I will boot this coffee  Oh  oh sorry sorry hey I'm sorry I apologize  so much I don't I don't need to do that  I'm sorry I didn't need to say I was  sorry just now sorry Tim Horton's who's  that there's a guy here dating maybe you  could stir it with a tiny hockey stick  or maple syrups better you don't want to  poutine some milk okay everybody I know  it's Friday let's try to get all of our  work done if you will boot that Julie  ate